Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie continued
to face challenges amid their ongoing
legal battle that's life isn't it you've
got challenges and you got some appeals
to face an email the actress wrote to
her ex-husband in January 2021
resurfaced on Tick Tock calling out
Brad's quote alcoholic Behavior
a former couple appear to be fighting
over their wine business miraval
Angelina and Brad are no stranger to the
court system and add this on the list of
the many cases that they have to deal
with including the custody battle in the
emotional letter Angelina details her
decision to sell her portion of the
Chateau she starts off writing quote it
is the place we brought the Twins home
to and where we were married over a
plaque in my mother's memory before
adding but it is also the place that
marks the beginning of the end of our
family and a business that is centered
around alcohol Angelina explains how
upsetting it is to reach this point and
says Brandt's made his commitment to the
business and alcohol painfully clear
quote I do not feel I can be involved
publicly or privately in a business
based on alcohol when alcoholic Behavior
harmed our family so deeply the actress
ends the message claiming miraval for me
died September 2016 and says the things
she's seen in the years since have sadly
confirmed that likely what Angeline is
referring to there is their 2016 private
jet incident which allegedly involved
Brad drunkenly abusing their children
just because Angelina Jolie has made
these accusations doesn't mean this
necessarily happened so where do they
stand now with their Winery well earlier
this year Angelina sold her stake of the
business to Russian oligarch Yuri
Scheffler prompting Brad to sue her
according to terms of their 2019 divorce
the bullet train actor claimed the two
had a mutual understanding that neither
of them could sell part of the winery
without the other's consent fast forward
to September now Angelina's former
company nouvelle filed a counterclaim
against Brad claiming he waged a
vindictive War to take control of the
Chateau this is a really high stakes
case not only is it personal between
Angelina and Brad there is a lot of
money at stake here according to court
documents he allegedly created a
years-long plan to seize the company
secretly moving assets to benefit
himself which ultimately devalued
Angelina's stake in the business Brad is
saying I wanted to continue to run this
business and continue to grow it so down
the line if I wanted to sell it it could
have been worth even more in response to
the filing a source told ET at the time
that it's quote yet another rehash and
repackaging of old material to try and
distract from the other party's own
behavior you look at your options and
you make the best decision and you carry
on
[Music]
thank you